on va passer au débat politique de ce
club et c'est évidemment cette grande
interview d'Elizabeth borne la première
ministre hier dans le Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France cabellier beaucoup
de sujets Alex on va voir évidemment ce
que dit la première ministre mais avant
de parler du fond de l'interview est-ce
que faire une grande interview comme ça
à la fin des 100 jours quelques jours
avant la prise de parole d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est on peut y voir le signe
Elisabeth borne reste à Matignon a
priori oui c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
lire et l'interpréter parce que une
première ministre ou un premier ministre
en partance serait plutôt en règle
générale discret n'a clairement quand on
regarde à la fois j'allais dire la forme
et le fond on est sur une première
ministre qui se projette dans l'avenir
donc on peut considérer que de toute
façon il n'y a pas j'allais dire
d'hypothèse d'un départ
d'Elizabeth borne d'autant plus que bon
on en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas tellement de
cartes en main pour l'instant compte
tenu du contexte
en tout cas qu'elle est bien décidée
avec Emmanuel Macron parce que les
petites surpris souvenez-vous Édouard
Philippe à l'époque on a la restitution
je crois de la convention citoyenne sur
le climat il les mains dans la main avec
Édouard Philippe il passe par les petits
jardins ils arrivent devant les citoyens
et doivent Philippe s'assoit et il lance
des grands projets en disant le premier
Miss floral le premier sporat le premier
se fera rien parce que quelques jours
plus tard il est pas là et donc ce
faisant il faut faire extrêmement
attention il est pas certain
qu'Elizabeth borne elle-même connaisse
exactement quel est son sort ce qui
plaît en effet en sa faveur c'est pas
tant la forme c'est pas tant l'interview
c'est ce que dit Arnaud il y a des
contraintes politiques qui aujourd'hui
font que on ne voit pas vraiment de
meilleur candidats pour Matignon la
situation bah conduit à trouver
quelqu'un qui serait capable de
synthétiser une majorité et en même
temps et bien d'être complémentaire de
pas trop faire d'ombre Emmanuel Macron
bref actuellement c'est le mouton à 5
pattes et donc peut-être a-t-il des
candidats mais il nous en fait pas ils
nous ont fait pas part par ailleurs à la
veille des vacances à 14 juillet etc en
remaniement n'aurait probablement pas
les effets escomptés donc a priori on
n'y est pas mais encore une fois avec
Emmanuel Macron faut toujours être
prudent
qui ont été effectués avec des
changements de Premier ministre en
juillet déjà Laurent Fabius lorsqu'il
devient le plus jeune premier ministre
que donne François Mitterrand à la
France et nommé Premier ministre en
juillet et puis plus récemment Jean
Castex a été nommé en effet en juillet
le bon à la limite j'allais dire la
saisonnalité n'a strictement aucune
importance dans cette affaire la réalité
c'est que aujourd'hui en effet encore
une fois le contexte politique j'allais
dire ne prédestine pas un changement de
Premier ministre mais en effet il faut
être prudent allez on va voir ce que dit
Elisabeth dans cette interview Alex
d'abord elle est revenue sur ces
derniers jours sur les violences
urbaines et sur la préparation du 14
juillet effectivement même si le calme
est revenu après les émeutes l'heure est
à la vigilance pour le gouvernement à
l'approche du 14 juillet Elisabeth borne
a annoncé l'interdiction de la vente du
port et du transport de mortier
d'artifice à cette occasion seuls les
professionnels qui organiseront les feux
d'artifice dans les communes pourront en
acheter et puis la première ministre
s'est exprimée sur les mesures que va
prendre le gouvernement pour éviter que
ce type de violence est de dégradation
ne se reproduisent et une amende aux
parents des jeunes qui participeraient
est en cours de réflexion au sein du
gouvernement je cite Elisabeth borne
aujourd'hui quand un adulte commet un
acte de cette nature on peut avoir
recours à une amende forfaitaire c'est
rapide et efficace ce n'est pas possible
pour les mineurs nous allons donc
construire un dispositif qui le
permettent et puis sur l'analyse de
cette séquence et sur la situation des
banlieues en France et bien Elisabeth
borne souhaite prendre du temps et
rappel des faits rappels des chiffres un
tiers des communes qui ont connu des
violences non pas de quartiers
politiques de la ville elle et la moitié
des quartiers qui font l'objet de
grosses opérations de rénovation urbaine
n'ont pas connu de violence les faits se
sont ceux-là évitons les raccourcis trop
rapide notez que le projet loi d'urgence
pour aider les communes à reconstruire
les bâtiments publics dégradés sera
présenté cette semaine en conseil des
ministres et les abeilles borne après
émeutes Arnaud
après ce qui s'est passé je vois pas un
premier ministre tenir un autre discours
que celui de l'autorité et de la fermeté
surtout compte tenu de l'état de
l'opinion publique qui est quand même en
demande d'autorité et de fermeté
vis-à-vis de ce type d'événements mais
j'allais dire qu'elle fait presque dure
en même temps c'est à dire que en effet
elle affiche la fermeté elle a un
discours qui vise à montrer la nécessité
de restaurer l'action et l'autorité de
l'État mais en même temps elle si vous
voulez elle elle parle de la politique
de la ville et elle note que en effet un
tiers des villes ou des quartiers qui
ont été touchés par ces émeutes ne
bénéficie pas des mesures liées aux
politiques publiques de la ville donc
elle est à la fois sur les deux
registres le registre du régalien et le
registre du social au moment où vous
avez finalement deux lectures qui
s'affrontent vis-à-vis de ces événements
une lecture que je qualifierais en effet
plus social qui consiste à dire oui les
politiques de la ville ont certes échoué
mais parce qu'on en fait pas
suffisamment et puis il y a ceux qui
considèrent qu'on en a fait beaucoup sur
les politiques sociales et les
politiques de réhabilitation en matière
de politique de la ville mais que
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est rétablir
l'autorité la fermeté de l'État et
vraisemblable est vraisemblablement
aussi peut-être une vision assimilatrice
qui est plus conforme au logiciel
républicain
c'est vrai mais sur c'est sur le les
deux sujets en réalité il y a pas de
changement de paradigme c'est à dire que
il y a pas vraiment fait d'annonce enfin
le fait d'interdire les mortiers
d'artifice je pense qu'en effet tout
d'un coup le fait que les mortiers
d'artifices venant des pays de l'Est
soit interdits ça ça va faire que il y
aura plus des matures bennes et que il y
aura plus d'attaque des policiers à
coups de mortiers d'artifice vous voyez
on est quand même à la fois dans une
forme de constat qui serait intéressant
de la part d'un commentateur en même
temps quelques effets d'annonce qui ne
changeront pas fondamentalement la donne
mais structurellement comment est-ce
qu'on règle aujourd'hui à la fois le
volet social et sécuritaire concernant
ces quartiers comment est-ce qu'on se
prépare demain si jamais il doit y avoir
une saison 2 ou 3 je sais pas si on
prend 2005 comme un temps précédent ou
pas de la Coupe du monde de rugby ou
lors des Jeux olympiques là-dessus on
n'a pas forcément de réponse tout à fait
évidente et donc aujourd'hui on a un
problème il semble s'être réglé lui-même
donc partons du principe que il ne
serait dîtra pas et qu'on va on va finir
heureux comme ça mais là dessus le
politique encore une fois échoue par
manque d'action un mot sur la question
des mineurs puisqu'elle en parle comment
sanctionner les mineurs participent à
ses émeutes alors les républicains ils
proposent de suspendre le RSA pour les
parents de ses enfants la première
ministre elle dit que le gouvernement
réfléchit à une amende spécifique dès la
première connerie comme le dit Emmanuel
Macron oui et puis la vérité c'est que
l'idée c'est une idée qui avait déjà été
exprimée par le Président de la
République lorsque il avait pris la
parole
j'allais dire au moment de l'épicentre
des des émeutes c'est la responsabilité
des parents on responsabilise les
parents ont responsabilise les familles
et donc on va en effet réfléchir
éventuellement
à la question des prestations sociales
d'ailleurs je note il y a quelques jours
il y a un sondage réalisé par l'Ifop qui
montrait que 70% des Français étaient
favorables à la suspension des
allocations familiales pour les familles
dont les enfants faisaient partie des
métiers donc si vous voulez la première
ministre elle fait de la politique aussi
et elle entend l'opinion publique et
elle entend que il y a ce besoin de
fermeté sauf que non alors sauf qu'elle
va pas dans le sens des LR elle essaie
de d'aller sur une ligne de crête et
trouver une voie médiane d'autant plus
que on a entendu ce week-end je crois
l'un de ces ministres le ministre de
l'éducation nationale être très réservé
par exemple sur la question des
allocations familiales et des sanctions
qui pouvaient en suivre pour les
familles des mineurs donc
elle est vraiment sur une ligne
intermédiaire ou à la fois elle fait
elle soigne l'aile gorge de sa majorité
tout en envoyant des signaux à l'opinion
publique et elle a le droit
ça pose plusieurs questions d'abord
quand vous avez une famille
monoparentale avec une mère qui part à
7h du matin voir à 5h du matin et qui
revient à 19h le soir voir à 23h parce
que et bien il faut bien gagner de
l'argent et que vous avez des enfants
les CEMM est-ce que vraiment on va la
sanctionner parce que et bien il y a pas
ces enfants ont fait une connerie c'est
pas si évident donc il y a un problème
de principe le deuxième problème il est
potentiellement juridique parce que il
faut à la fois un peu alors on n'est pas
dans le domaine pénal mais malgré tout
et bien il faut être certain que il y a
une faute qui était commis par le parent
et donc est-ce que vraiment ça va
résister ou fourche coding du jeune
administratif de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme etc ou du Conseil
mensuel c'est un objet de passer par la
loi c'est pas évident donc à ce stade là
on est quand même face à une annonce qui
reste une annonce extrêmement fragile et
qui conduit quand même et sur le
principe ça va paraît embêtant de dire
aux parents bah écoutez l'État n'est pas
capable de gérer aujourd'hui l'ordre
public on a besoin de vous et donc ce
faisant on vous met la pression pour que
vous assuriez l'option de l'État en
effet il y a un rôle des familles mais
ce rôle des familles l'État ne peut pas
les contraindre à l'assumer donc il y a
une politique familiale il y a peut-être
une éducation des parents à faire il y a
en tout cas un rôle à revaloriser de
l'école parce qu'il est bien gentil à
peine mais aujourd'hui quand vous avez
un enseignant en banlieue accompagne ton
saignante quand vous avez un enseignant
en banlieue qui tente de rétablir
l'ordre et qui n'est pas soutenu par sa
hiérarchie et bien la réalité c'est que
là aussi elle se perd l'autorité et là
vous avez un agent public à cet agent
public il veut faire son boulot le
problème c'est que le ministère lui ne
le fait pas derrière et donc si jamais
exactement donc il serait peut-être
temps que l'État balaye devant sa porte
avant d'aller balayer devant celle des
familles
c'est-à-dire que la question de
l'éducation et de l'éducation nationale
est à mon avis centrale le déclassement
de l'éducation nationale et une des
racines des problèmes auxquels nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui le
déplacement à tous les niveaux
d'ailleurs
et la suite de cette interview Elisabeth
Bank a également dressé le en décembre
post-réforme des retraites effectivement
souvenez-vous après la promulgation de
la réforme des retraites Emmanuel Macron
avait dressé la feuille de route
d'Elizabeth borne avec plusieurs
chantiers à lancer en 100 jours bilan
d'étape qui sera donc fait le 14 juillet
et Isabelle borne d'une certaine manière
a déjà fait son propre bilan elle estime
que tous les chantiers sont au vert je
la cite sur le chant du travail par
exemple ce sont quatre réformes qui sont
faites ou engagées à sur un chômage
retraite lycée professionnel France
travail en matière d'ordre républicain
qui était le deuxième chantier fixé par
Emmanuel Macron et bien trois grandes
lois régaliennes votées ou en voie de
lettres en faveur de la police et des
armées et de la justice et puis enfin
les deux feuilles de route sur
l'éducation à la santé ont été déployés
avec également une planification
écologique livrée alors justement le
plan pour l'écologie d'Elisabeth borne
il n'a pas pu être présenté à cause des
émeutes mais la première ministre a
annoncé qu'il y aura 7 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour financer la
transition écologique en 20 et puis en
revanche dans ce bilan et bien il y a un
texte qui bloque c'est le projet de loi
d'immigration le gouvernement n'a
toujours pas de majorité solide sur ce
texte mais selon Elisabeth borne et bien
les discussions continuent avec les
républicains on va revenir sur la
question de l'immigration mais elle se
dresse un satisfait site sur son bilan
des 100 jours oui visiblement la
situation va bien mieux qu'il y a 100
jours non mais évidemment c'est à dire
qu'on a eu des textes qui ont été
adoptés qui étaient des textes
relativement consensuels ou en tout cas
qui pouvait trouver une majorité et
après tout on pourrait se satisfaire de
ça pendant quatre ans vous savez sous la
Troisième République on gouvernait comme
ça c'est à dire que vous aviez un
président du conseil il construisait des
majorités Haddock et pas encore groupe
de groupes structurer ça arrivera après
1910 voir après 1920 ici au Sénat donc
si vous voulez c'est possible de
gouverner comme ça c'est possible de
tenir le pays comme ça en revanche
l'idée qui est la nôtre en réalité
depuis le milieu du XXe siècle vous avez
un gouvernement ce gouvernement il a un
vrai programme de gouvernement qui est
un programme de changement et que il
l'applique il est en capacité de
s'engager à long terme là où
actuellement on n'y est pas parce que
évidemment il n'y a pas de majorité le
principal mandat qui avait donné
Emmanuel Macron Elizabeth borne mandat
impossible on va pas se mentir c'était
justement d'élargir cette majorité de
construire un projet de gouvernement et
de pouvoir avancer sur ce terrain là le
problème évidemment c'est que c'est
malgré tout une mission impossible que
pour arriver à mener ça il faudrait
tenir d'un côté la gauche de renaissance
le modèle et de l'autre côté la droite
de LR parce que les députés LR élu en
2022 ce sont en règle générale les plus
à droite du parti et donc aujourd'hui
cet espace politique trouver quelqu'un
qui l'incarne qui le tienne qui le
structure et ben c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas dans les mains d'Emmanuel
Macron et c'est clairement au dessus
n'ont pas des compétences mais des
possibilités d'action d'Elisabeth borne
ouais on va parler de la majorité
d'abord un mot sur le fond Arnaud un de
ces 100 jours et les Abed bornes elle
redit la priorité en tout cas au cœur
des priorités c'est la transition
écologique
oui mais parce que si vous voulez bon la
transition écologique même s'il y a des
désaccords qui existent entre les
différentes forces politiques c'est
malgré tout un sujet qui est aujourd'hui
à peu près consensuel et encore et
encore mais j'allais dire c'est presque
sans risque
la vérité c'est que premier constat
c'est qu'en effet le mandat qui avait
été donné à travers cette formule un peu
communicante des 100 jours c'était que
la Premier ministre la première ministre
essaye en effet d'élargir le chant de sa
majorité clairement aujourd'hui c'est
pas le cas et de ce point de vue là elle
ne pouvait pas de son y parvenir aux
raisons du en raison du contexte du
contexte politique ensuite le sujet
essentiel Benjamin faisait la
comparaison entre la troisième et la
Cinquième République sauf que nous
n'avons plus les mêmes cultures
politiques entre la 5ème et la Troisième
République les institutions d'une
certaine manière ont changé la culture
politique du pays la France a été un
régime parlementaire
en sous la Troisième sous la Quatrième
public avec un fonctionnement qui
permettait des compromis quoi qu'avec
une très grande instabilité politique
quand même faut rappeler quand même que
la Quatrième République est tombé entre
autres du fait de son instabilité
politique au moment de la guerre
d'Algérie là avec la Cinquième
République on est dans un tout autre
contexte institutionnel les
initiateurs de la Constitution ont voulu
apporter de la stabilité aux
institutions c'était ça leur grande idée
et ils l'ont apporté comment on
rationalisant le Parlement mais surtout
également avec un mode de scrutin qui
était le mode de scrutin majoritaire une
inominal à deux tours qui dégageait des
majorités stables aujourd'hui depuis les
élections de 2022 nous n'avons plus ce
contexte politique c'est-à-dire que
évidemment les initiateurs des
institutions de la 5ème république
n'avaient pas prévu la fragmentation du
champ politique que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui et cette fragmentation
aujourd'hui elle pèse considérablement
j'allais dire sur l'exercice du mandat
du second mandat d'Emmanuel Macron
Macron et reste confronté à un sujet qui
est un sujet central depuis des
élections législatives de 2022 ils ne
dispose pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que c'est tenable comme
cela jusqu'à
2027 moi ça me paraît extrêmement
compliqué sur la distance oui pour
revenir sur ce que disait Arnaud le mode
de scrutin majoritaire à deux tours qui
est l'un des éléments central si on veut
comprendre nos institutions et qui
d'ailleurs est pas dans la conscience et
dans la loi
il était également en pratique sous la
Troisième République et comme le disait
bien Arnaud alors dans des conditions
très différentes et bien à l'époque vous
aviez des majorités très variables très
volatiles et des changements de
gouvernement relativement fréquents donc
c'est pas le mode de scrutin c'est toute
une espace et toute une structure
politique or à quoi on assistait
dernièrement à quoi on assistait lors
des dernières législatives à une
modification de notre espace politique
avec au moins une tripolarisation ça
avec le même mode de scrutin ça produit
pas du tout les mêmes institutions et
donc là on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation très particulière on a sous la
Cinquième République biberonner à l'idée
que il y a un individu individu dirige
et cet individu à l'époux allait pouvoir
et la capacité d'appliquer un programme
or ça aujourd'hui au vu de la
conjugaison entre nos institutions le
mode de scrutin et l'espace politique ça
ne produit plus ça et en effet il y a
d'un côté des Français et un Emmanuel
Macron qui considèrent que et ben voilà
il y a un président et ce président il a
le pouvoir mais de l'autre côté la
possibilité d'exercer ce pouvoir est
aujourd'hui très limité et si demain il
devait y avoir des solutions ce que
donne à voir les enquêtes et les
élections partielles c'est qu'on aura à
peu près la même assemblée
peut-être une analyse sur le fond sur ce
fameux bilan d'Elizabeth band sur ces
trois chantiers des 100 jours si
justement on les regarde à l'aune
notamment de ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours avec les violences
urbaines ce chantier numéro 2 de l'ordre
républicain et de la justice on voit
qu'il y a quand même et ben un gros un
gros problème avec la France qui
s'embrasse et puis une fracture qui est
encore plus visible entre la police et
la population donc ça vraiment c'est à
pointer le travail reste encore à faire
sur la question du chantier numéro le
travail alors certes il y a plusieurs
lois qui sont en train d'être passé au
Parlement mais il y a quand même cette
question du nombre d'emplois pourvu avec
beaucoup de secteurs en tension qui ont
vraiment besoin de travailleurs de
candidats et qui ne les ont pas et donc
il y aura forcément la question de
l'immigration qui va revenir et ce
projet loi qui bloque avec et bien ce
sujet pour le gouvernement faut-il
régulariser ces travailleurs sans
papiers donc là aussi ce sera un vrai
sujet et puis sur l'amélioration des
services publics qui a été le troisième
chantier à lancer dans ces 100 jours
alors certes il y a eu des mesures sur
l'éducation la santé mais concernant la
santé dans l'hôpital il y a une grande
crainte des services d'urgence par
exemple pour cet été sur le grand âge et
les failles aussi du service public du
grand âge il y aura pas de loi grand âge
il y aura des petites mesures par-ci par
là est-ce que ça va suffire c'est pas
sûr et Alex vous parliez de
l'immigration un mot parce que c'est
peut-être le texte le symbole de ces
difficultés à trouver une majorité
Olivier du socle nous le disait pas de
texte en juillet contrairement à ce qui
avait été initialement promis mais aussi
bien lui que se disent optimise sur un
accord avec les républicains c'est un
peu la méthode Coué où ils ont raison
d'être ton petit truc cette affaire du
texte sur l'immigration c'est en train
de devenir un serpent de mer parce que
on a vu
l'exécutif maintenant depuis plusieurs
mois j'avais dire changer de pied à la
fois sur le format passant sur le
contenu et une fine et ce texte sur
l'immigration pour qu'il soit adopté il
faut absolument que une partie des
républicains voir la majeure partie le
vote sauf que les républicains entre
temps ont mis la barre assez haut en la
matière pour l'exécutif et donc on voit
que sur cette affaire aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas pour l'instant de conditions qui
sont réunies pour que l'on puisse
véritablement dégager une majorité et ça
va être un instant de vérité très
important parce que
les républicains en tout cas si l'on
entend les déclarations d'un certain
nombre d'entre eux a commencé par
Monsieur Marleix
menaces l'exécutif d'une éventuelle
motion de censure sur ce texte et là en
la matière le risque n'est pas
négligeable pour que cette motion puisse
être le moment venu adopter donc il est
clair que pour l'exécutif il y a un vrai
sujet sur cette question d'immigration
d'autant plus que il y a une attente
très forte sur cette question de
l'opinion publique là aussi toutes les
études d'opinion le montrent
c'est le moment de vérité ça sera le
moment de vérité ce texte immigration ça
va être l'un des moments de vérité en
effet tout bêtement parce que qu'est-ce
qui différencie aujourd'hui sur le
logiciel idéologique LR du gouvernement
bah c'est pas tellement les sujets
économiques qu'on a quand même deux
orientations qui sont sociales libérales
libéral social etc c'est la question en
effet du régalien de l'identité etc en
tout cas c'est comme ça que LR veut se
positionner et c'est l'espace politique
qui peut éventuellement être construit
pour LR donc forcément si LR vote le
texte et bien quelle est la différence
entre LR et le gouvernement allez dire
aux européennes ensuite ben voter pour
la liste LR parce que le gouvernement
en marche c'est pas nous qui allez
projeter un candidat en 2027 avec un
logiciel qui sera à peu près le logiciel
de la majorité sortante tel qu'il serait
perçu par l'opinion c'est compliqué donc
il faut arriver à cliver en sous la
Cinquième République si vous voulez
incarner l'alternance il faut incarner
l'alternative donc il faut apparaître
comme étant au moins en rupture
symbolique vis-à-vis de la majorité
précédente mais en même temps pour elle
ne pas voter un texte qui quand même
risque de reprendre un certain nombre
d'éléments de son programme c'est
complexe d'où une forme non pas de
radicalisation mais en tout cas je
dirais de polarisation du logiciel LR
ces derniers mois pour montrer que il y
a une vraie différence entre la majorité
et LR donc en effet ça paraît
extrêmement extrêmement compliqué et
pour le gouvernement à sa témoigne
aujourd'hui qu'avec une majorité
relative vous ne faites pas ce que vous
voulez avec une majorité relative vous
ne pouvez faire vous pouvez faire voter
que des textes dans lequel et bien une
grande partie de l'opposition se
retrouve et qui n'apparaissent pas comme
étant trop politique parce que sinon ma
personne ne vous soutient merci
on va encore Arnaud pour terminer cette
émission elle est dans l'extrême sud
de l'île Audrey vital nous emmène
découvrir les remparts de Bonifacio
l'emblème de la ville c'est puissant
rempart qui ceinture la citadelle depuis
plus de 1000 ans mais ils sont mis en
péril par le temps et par les éléments
la mairie entreprise les rénover avec
l'aide de l'État un projet de plus de 15
millions d'euros
au bout d'une presqu'île vissez sur un
promontoire rocheux à deux pas de la
Sardaigne s'élève la citadelle de
Bonifacio point militaire stratégique
depuis plus de 1000 ans
corsaires dans un premier temps puis dès
la fin du 12e siècle la cité est devenue
une colonie génoise qui va tout à la
fois l'urbaniser et continuer de la
fortifier ce sont vraiment les Génois à
partir du 13e siècle qui vont donner
tout le caractère qu'on connaît à
Bonifacio et en faire une place forte de
gêne dans la Méditerranée depuis son
rempart viennent ceinturer la citadelle
et protéger le port de commerce en
contrebas des remparts renforcés strat
après strat jusqu'au 20e siècle ils
incarnent l'identité de Bonifacio une
identité est mise en péril à cause du
temps et des éléments Bonifacio est une
zone très très volonté avec des vents
dominants très forts qui viennent comme
ça juste en face de nous
compare protecteur devenu peu à peu
dentelle et même dangereux prêt à
s'effondrer et interdit au public
pendant des années on était venu il y a
une quinzaine d'années et c'était pas du
tout comme ça on n'avait pas accès
justement pour descendre un peu plus bas
depuis quelques semaines c'est à nouveau
possible après un chantier d'ampleur à 5
millions d'euros une première partie la
batterie Saint-François vient d'être
rendue à ses visiteurs il y a une vue
incroyable sur tout le golf sur toutes
les falaises c'est magnifique moi c'est
la première fois que que je visite c'est
la première fois que j'arrive ici
franchement j'ai jamais vu ça ailleurs
c'était mon vent de voir
ses remparts qui sont un patrimoine de
la Corse de la France de l'Europe
qui retrouve cette qualité comme vous
pouvez le voir c'est c'est vraiment très
très beau le chemin de ronde a été
rénové des meurtrières et des
échauguettes refaçonnées avec des
matériaux spécialement pensés il fallait
que l'on réhab
Bonifacio est à deux heures de toutes
les capitales européennes et je pense
qu'un touriste peut venir à Bonifacio
bien sûr pour voir nos falaises et nos
plages mais il pourra venir aussi en
octobre en novembre en mars il venir y
apprendre l'histoire de la Méditerranée
une partie de l'histoire de l'Europe la
rénovation des deux kilomètres de
rempart devrait se terminer d'ici 10 ans
par le bastion de l'étendard unique
porte d'entrée de la ville jusqu'au 19e
siècle et voilà pour ces magnifiques
images de drève Vita Arnaud on va pas
dire le contraire merci merci à Audrey
on regarde ce qu'elle est une de nos
quotidiens jeunot Alex
[Musique]
et on commence par la Provence La
Provence qui titres sur la disparition
du petit Émile dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence
est porté disparu depuis samedi soir il
se trouvait chez ses grands-parents dans
la commune du Vernet dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence il aurait
échappé à leur surveillance depuis un
important dispositif de recherche a été
mise en place gendarme pompier équipe
cynophile sont mobilisés sans oublier
les citoyens volontaires qui participent
aux recherches la Provence qui livre
aussi aujourd'hui le témoignage d'un
jeune Marseillais tombé dans le coma
après avoir reçu un tir de flash-ball
dans la tempe en marge des émeutes à
Marseille il est sorti du coma et les
souffrent d'un traumatisme crânien et
juste après le tir il affirme avoir été
passé à passer à tabac par Saint-Côme
qui l'identifie comme des policiers d'un
équipage de la BAC elle a une de l'union
avec ses émeut les soldes des
commerçants oui les violences de début
juillet ont coupé l'élan des soldes
d'été les pillages et l'insécurité ont
découragé de nombreux clients alors même
si le gouvernement a prolongé d'une
semaine la période des soldes pas sûr
que cela suffise à rattraper les pertes
de ses commerçants la période et
d'autant plus difficile que le secteur
du prêt-à-porter connaît une profonde
mutation et victime de l'inflation
aujourd'hui les clients doivent choisir
entre faire les magasins ou partir en
vacances résume un commerçant de
Charleville-Mézières les violons orages
de ces derniers jours ont fait des
dégâts et oui avec cette photo
spectaculaire de l'incendie de l'église
de Descartes un petit village
d'Indre-et-Loire c'était la Une de La
Nouvelle République la foudre a frappé
l'édifice le toit de l'église et le
clocher se sont embrasés les oeuvres
d'art de cette église qui est classée
ont été mis à l'abri et le Conseil
départemental c'est des gens engagés à
financer la reconstruction alors même si
ces orages ont fait du bien ces
dernières semaines au cours d'eau ce ne
sera pas suffisant pour éviter la
sécheresse cet été estime le journal La
Dépêche du Midi notamment parce que les
pluies d'orage ne sont pas efficaces
elles sont brutales pénètre pas les sols
desséchés et elles font juste monter le
niveau des cours d'eau pour se déverser
dans la mer la sécheresse qui fait
également la une du Berry républicain et
qui cause beaucoup de soucis à nos
agriculteurs puisque les feux de culture
se multiplient hier par exemple la
Bourges 6 hectares de blé ont brûlé de
mauvaises augure pour la moisson et qui
est effectué actuellement et puis dans
le Var l'alerte canicule est lancé c'est
elle a une de Var-Matin le niveau
d'alerte orange et déclaré dans le
département alors que c'est déjà le cas
dans le département voisin des
Alpes-Maritimes et Var-Matin donne
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui quelques conseils
pour s'adapter à la canicule fermer les
volets la journée et aérer la nuit boire
au moins 1,5 litres d'eau par jour et
essayer de passer trois heures par jour
dans des endroits frais comme le cinéma
ou elle est grande surfaces
du Tour de France effectivement et on va
parler du Puy-de-Dôme il y a pas de
raison on parle de l'accord si on parle
aussi depuis dôme
en France voilà tout le monde en premier
son splato et plusieurs journaux
régionaux reviennent sur l'étape de
montagne hier en Auvergne Michael Woods
c'est imposé hier au sommet du volcan du
Puy-de-Dôme dans un final fusionné avec
le public c'est à la une de la montagne
et puis au sommet du classement général
et bien pogatcher continue de réduire
l'écart avec le maillot jaune étonnant
du titre Wingard 17 secondes les
séparent j'en ai de repas
Clermont-Ferrand la plus belle ville de
France maintenant la plus belle ville de
France dans le plus beau département de
France dans la plus belle région de
France qui a disparu l'Auvergne mais qui
malgré tout continuer à rester dans nos
cœurs oh là là c'est beau
pour la Corse la prochaine fois nous
merci beaucoup Benjamin Morel merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci Le Breton on
se retrouve demain Alex si vous voulez
voir revoir cette émission c'est sur
public sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous à
18h sans public Thomas Hugues et puis à
19h30 et Elisabeth Martichoux reçoit le
ministre de la Santé François Brown et
nous on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée
[Musique]